and welcome back everyone first of all I
want to start by thanking the organizers
as well as the entire staff at Simons
for just pulling together this entire
workshop during these trying times I
hope everybody is doing well and yeah
that let's get started so good news as
far as bad news the good news is that
maybe some of you might be a little
bored seeing all these matrices and
tents ring and all these products so I
talked is going to be a little more
general it's like it's not going to dive
into all these lattice details but the
bad news is also that I'm not going to
dive into all these lattice details so
you might feel like oh it's a lattice
talk maybe we need to get into those
details but we'll get into some
technical aspects as well towards the
end but yeah it's going to be pretty
broad talk hopefully all right so the
talk is about something called mixed
functional corruption which I believe is
quite a powerful notion of encryption
and to basically show that why it's
powerful I'm going to describe some
applications of this concept to
introduce increasing capabilities in
modern other encryption systems so the
starting point of this talk is the
concept of functional induction which
saw its roots as early as in 2005 so we
all know public traditional public
induction which basically solves the
problem of secure one-to-one
communication Alice wants to send a
message to Bob and Bob wants to learn
the entire message if it has the secret
key function encryption on the other
hand it allows a much more fine-grained
access control over the data so now you
want a decryptor to not only learn the
you want the dieter to learn some
partial information about the encrypted
data not the data completely so
pictorially this can be understood as
follows
suppose we have Alice and Bob our two
favorite parties Alice has some private
sensitive function or some predicates
that it has with it and what it wants is
that it wants any party in the system to
learn some partial information about
this predicate F basically what you can
imagine is that any party in the system
could have some input with it
for instance Bob could have an input X
and what Bob wants to learn is the
evaluation of the function of the secret
function on its public input X that's
all so this can be solved using the
notion of function encryption as follows
in function encryption you can sample
the master keys now using the master
secret key the authority can sample a
partial secret key a decryption key for
Bob for input X sin
he over to Bob and now using a master
public key Alex can encrypt the
sensitive information create a self text
and send this a text over the broad
public Channel
now what Bob can do is that Bob can take
this decryption key and the celtics and
it can learn some partial information
about the function which is going to be
f of X not the full function but just f
of X and intuitively the security
requirement for function Krypton states
the following it states that any
non-trivial information about the
intrepid data should be hidden from the
adversity so what is the non-trivial
information in this case suppose an
adversity gets to see a polynomial e
many functional secret keys for safe
inputs X 1 X 2 up to X Q and it gets to
see a safe text which encrypts some
policy function f then we want that this
ciphertext should hide as much
information about F as possible and it
should only reveal what you can learn by
performing bigger trick honestly so
basically the moves you can only learn f
of X 1 f of X 2 and so on
so that's the intuition behind
functional encryption now as a and yeah
before moving on throughout this talk
I'm going to refer to the safe X policy
variant of function reduction usually in
function adoption we are more used to
encrypting messages and giving out
secret keys of functions Here I am
switching the semantics and going to
encrypt functions I want to hide
functions and I'm going to give out
secret keys for inputs it's sort of like
a duel begin but it's going to be useful
for the rest of the talk I'm going to
stick with this way so it'd be better
just to switch your semantics in your
head to subtext policy variant all right
so function proficient as I was alluding
to earlier it's a very powerful
primitive it in some senses has turned
out to be the holy grail of modern
recovery
why because we can realize we have seen
by now that function encryption actually
captures a wide variety of different
interruption systems and why did I give
different crypto applications for
instance we can actually just
instantiate I be a simple instantiation
of function encryption cells you can
also instantiate attribute based
encryption using a simple function
classes in function encryption so just
recall what is attribute based
encryption as venkat I wrote them and
everybody else they told the about a
cubic base encryption in actively
business efficient an injector wants to
hide a message M but
under some policy fie and what you want
to do is that a Decrypter will have some
attributes with itself and the detector
can learn the message as long as the
attributes satisfy the policy function
under which the message was encrypted so
basically this type of conduction system
is called attribute based encryption
system and it can be visual it can be
instantiated using a general-purpose
function encryption or just this
function simple function class of
compare comparison at C of X is equal to
1 and then outputting the message n now
a national question at this point might
be ok we already have constructions for
identity based encryption activities
encryption and more from standard
assumptions so when does this function
corruption thing get too powerful what
about suppose we consider the function
classes of log web circus nc1 what
happens in that case now a couple of
years ago we saw that function efficient
for just NC one it is already quite
powerful because it helps us in building
a bridge from this Fe for NC one either
to this wonderful magical island of
obfuscation which as we have seen from
all the talks yesterday and today is
like a cryptographic magic languor of
wonderland where so many amazing things
exist but we don't know how to get to
that island from just channel
assumptions so a natural question at
this point might be okay if we for NC 1
might be a bit tricky
what about certain relaxation is a
function caption what if you want to
just consider some small function
classes an idea could be consider some
shallow circuits shallow depth circuits
like NC 0 circuits or constant degree
circuits but as you heard yesterday from
schrieffer's saw from Rachel's I met a
nice talk
these are already quite powerful because
they already give you off the station
too so maybe just NC 0 and constant
degree circuits are still too powerful
ok maybe this is too powerful but what
about if we work only in the seated key
setting I see her yesterday again even
see tricky setting in even in the CTD
setting function reduction is quite
powerful because that also gives us a
pathway to obfuscation with that maybe
ok maybe it's not clear what are the
relaxation or function impression could
be but this one nice relaxation which is
called the bounded collision security
model so recall in the general security
model what we have is that we allow the
adversary to make an unbounded number of
secret key queries that allows the
adversity to learn an unbound
about the ciphertext that encrypts about
the function that isn't kept inside the
ciphertext in the bounded collision
model we say that the adversary gets to
see a bounded number of secret keys what
that means is that during the system
setup we fix upper bound on the total
number of corruptions that the adversity
can do and all the system algorithm all
the algorithm the system can grow with
that particular bound so the good news
over here is that we actually have very
nice constructions of moment collision
function division comes and assumptions
but a bit of a problematic thing is that
it's quite it's quite neat but it has
limited applications why because the
security definition of this this bomb
and collision security is a bit brittle
because as long as as soon as the
adversity gets to see even one more
query just Q plus 1 queries then the
security completely breaks down so
what's the current lag landscape looks
something like this on the left side we
have this standard assumption wonderful
island we know how to get these
primitives like identity based
encryption
ad and much more and on the right side
we have this wonderful function adoption
island that we want to get to because it
will open up this one this paradise of
cryptographic applications a question at
this point would be maybe function
encryption is a step too far right now
but is there a feasible middle ground or
a feasible middle island that we can get
you and that's the point of this talk in
this talk or in this work line of what
we propose a middle island that we call
mixed function encryption that lies
somewhere in between these in between
these tools and it opens up some nice
applications that were previously
unknown from standard options and we're
only known from function interruption or
obfuscation for example so any questions
up to this point that what the landscape
looks like and about function encryption
generally okay
all right so now let me just define what
max function encryption is I mean this
is what I'm proposing to be a very nice
powerful way of encryption right so you
know function encryption by now mix
function reduction is just like a
regular function encryption scheme
except now it's a bimodal system what I
mean that bimodal system is that it has
to interruption modes instead of just a
single encryption there is a public key
encryption mode and
a secret induction mode and you can
encrypt functions in both the modes and
as well it will become clearer that
having these two moons is quite useful
if you have some others nice properties
so let's just try to pictorial in
understand what's happening
so recall in the public key mode or just
in the regular function encryption
scheme this is what was happening an
analyst could encrypt the message and
crypt the function using the mass public
key and that suffix can be decrypted by
Bob and Bob can learn some partial
information just this function
evaluation on its input X a mixed
function efficient scheme has this
public mode where you can encrypt sap
you can compute subjects in the public
key mode but also has there's dark mode
in this dark mode one can compute cypher
text using the master secret key not the
master public key but the master secret
key instead and such as text also
provide this functional correctness
property that you can learn some partial
information about the function f that
wasn't with it not the entire function
so algorithmically this can be
understood as follows so we have a set
of algorithm that generates the master
public and a master secret key now we
have this regular public encryption
algorithm this white box but also we
have this black box of the secret
encryption algorithm what these
algorithms do is that they take as input
their respective master keys the public
and secret keys and they also take us
input a function f that you want to
encrypt and they compute the ciphertext
and what you can do is that you can
decrypt the cipher text along with this
partial secret E and learn the
evaluation of the function on that
particular input X I mean at this point
you might be wondering I mean what is
really happening
you are just encrypting if you already
have a public key mode why do you have
the secret email at all it seems a bit
stupid what's really the point of all
these things so the point lies in
somewhat in the details so the details
are as follows so what's X here as case
of X you mean yeah absolutely
okay sure I should just have to so SK
sub X is the functional secret key is
just a partial secret key that you
generate using the master secret key by
running X here you made F no no no X
over here I meant just the input X
that's it f is the so I'm considering
the size
policy variant of function encryption
where the cipher takes the encrypt
functions and secret is they contain
inputs so I'm just switching the
semantics from the usually policy to
suffix policy okay yeah so that's why
you need to be quite important I'm going
to stick to the ciphertext policy
billion for the entire talk okay so just
since you're answering questions there's
also question Ct is exactly the same in
both moles or just functionality yeah
okay so this is what I'm trying to get
at so good question
and nice timing so that's what I was
trying to get at that what's the point
if you already have a public key mode
which is producing a ciphertext why have
the secret key mode itself so the point
actually lies in how we define or how we
capture the secret key more so what
makes functional mix function captured
interesting and useful in terms of
applications is that we can actually
cause a rift between the function
classes that we can encrypt in the
public key mode and in the secret key
mode if we can create a noticeable gap
it might be useful that maybe you can't
encrypt a large variety of function the
public key mode but maybe you can
encrypt a few functions and they might
be useful so another point which makes
another point of introduct the the other
way we introduced some sort of
discrepancy in the mix function
reduction is by introducing discrepancy
in the security model so we require that
in the public key mode security is
provided only in a very strong sense but
in the city more view we provide a very
be crucial security so let me elaborate
what I mean here so the public key mode
in a mex function protection scheme it's
going to provide a very limited a
function class you can't encrypt
possibly all possible functions but
maybe the very small subset of function
classes
whereas in the secret key mode you might
be able to encrypt a large number of
functions on the other hand the public
key encryption mode since it's a public
key algorithm it provides a much
stronger security property now you
provide an unbounded collision resistant
security so the C so the adversity can
get to see an unmodern number of
ciphertext instead of a bounded number
of subjects whereas in the secret key
mode since it's a secret key algorithm a
master secret key algorithm the anniv
can only get to see a bounded number of
ciphertext
number of corruption or these c2d
subtext so on one hand we make public
key mode a little less useful by
limiting the expressivity but on the
other hand we make public a little more
useful by providing a stronger notion of
security for that and we switch things
around for the secret key mode and this
is what makes the notion of public or
this notion of mixed function corruption
interesting and useful for applications
so just trying to put that back into
this picture so we have these two
different function classes one for the
public key one for the secret encryption
mode and you can encrypt these subtext
and both these self text when you
decrypt them using the secret key you're
going to evaluate the function on your
given input X so f 1 of X in terms of
the public key algorithm public in
ciphertext and F 2 of X in for the
security subtext now what about security
so that's about correctness and how the
scheme seems to work for security we
require some standard properties like
the first property is what you could
expect we have a public induction mode
so why not just have the regular self
exciting property that we have in the
regular function reduction scheme it
says that given a public is a function f
1 and a bunch of secret keys the
university can only learn the trivial
information which it can learn by
running the decription algorithm but it
cannot learn any other information about
the function f 1 that was encrypted okay
so we had this property with the public
key mode what about the secret key mode
let's do something similar again we want
to say in the secret key mode if you
given an interruption of sequel function
f 2 and a bunch of secret keys you can
only learn the evaluation of the
function f 2 on those particular inputs
what we're going to do is that in the
secret key mode we are going to just
consider the bounded collusion variant
where the adversary can only get to see
a bounded number of secret key self text
in the public key mode since master
public is public you can get to encrypt
an unbounded number of Safa texts but in
the secret key mode you can only make
anomaly or just a bounded number of
queries to the secret induction
algorithm so these are two nice
properties but at this point some of you
might be scratching your head and you'd
be like okay so this is mixed function
exception but why is it more powerful or
more useful potentially then just and
simple amalgamation of a public key
function encryption scheme and a secret
key from filling deficients key
suppose we want to build a mixed on to
encryption scheme for public function
class F and secret function Class G why
not just take her ugly function [ __ ]
schinsky for function class F a secret
key function encryption for function
does G and just combine them those two
subjects append them together and that
might give us a mixed function
encryption so this is where our third
property comes into the picture
so this after exciting trophy but we
also want the mixed function encryption
ciphertext to hide the type of the so we
also want this the mixed function
caption to cipher text to hide the type
of the self text so if the adversary
cannot really distinguish between the
public is safe it means secretly septics
then it should not learn whether it
receive the public is FX or secretly
surf text so a little more formally this
is what we require from the scheme we
say that suppose an adversary is given
or normally many secret keys then the
adversity should not be able distinguish
a public key surf text which encrypts a
function f1 a secret a ciphertext which
encrypts function f2 as long as f1 and
f2
they both evaluate to the same value in
all particular inputs for which it has a
secret key for so this third property is
what ties together these public key and
secret key moves in in a very nice
manner and it's the most interesting
property for applications so any
questions about the notion of mixed
function encryption because this is very
crucial for the remaining talk yeah so I
think there's a question
but questions so in the question is in
practice will the secret key encryption
mode not occur is it just going to occur
in the proofs so let me yeah use I can't
seem to close the okay yeah so the
answer that question is actually no yeah
we're really going to use the security
mode itself in the terms of in the real
world itself but as you will see in
terms of applications this since the
secret encryption algorithm requires a
master secret key so this algorithm can
only be used by a party who actually can
come who can just break the system
security so looking ahead to traitor
tracing we are going to use the seated
encryption algorithm not in general in
terms of just broadcasting suffix but in
terms of performing some tracing
operations so it's going to be useful in
practice as well not in in not just in
truth okay so any yeah let's see so a
question is the number of secret key
queries is unbounded in both the modes
that is correct so the only thing that
is bounded is the number of secret key
encryption queries that you can get to
that you see the second question is
couldn't adversely simply request
multiple queries until the bounded
exhaust until the bound is exhausted
absolutely so there is an a priori fixed
bound suppose Q it were she can get to
see arbitrary queries until it exhausts
its okay so with that let me move on to
so this is the notion of mix function
encryption and let me move on to the
remaining talk so yeah before moving on
I'm going to introduce some notation
that's going to be useful in describing
the remaining ideas so I'm going to use
this picture this picture of two blocks
a black block and a white block where
this white block contains this function
f and this black block contains this
function G to denote a mixed function
efficient scheme for public function
class F and secret function class G and
this is going to be my shorthand
notation for a mixed X key
and just a quick recap so this is what
you want to remember for the remaining
talk a mixed function interruption
scheme is just like a regular function
reduction scheme except it has two modes
in the public key mode you can encrypt
using the public key and the secret key
more ease you can encrypt using secret
key and there are three security
properties that makes mix encryption
interesting which is the public's the
public key staff text hiding property
the secret key celtics hiding property
in which you want to hide the function
non-civil information of the function at
you encrypt and third and the most
interesting property is the public
secrets a fixed indistinguishable
property in which you want to hide the
mode of in this mode of encryption the
public mode of the secret key mode is
their passion so the big picture that
has been painted by a lot of these works
starting with our initial work in which
we propose the concert mix one in
encryption is asphalt so in the initial
work we started with learning with
errors and we gave a construction for
mix functional encryption in which the
public function class consisted of just
a single function the single function is
what I call the unity function the unity
function is just the constant one
function on any input X it basically
outputs one just the constant one
function but in the secret key mode you
can actually encrypt a larger much
larger function class which is log space
all all say all permutations branching
programs or non permutation plans
programs even then we were able to show
that you can actually lift this mixed
function which in construction in which
the public key mode only encrypts ID in
our only interests unity to ask more
powerful mixed function reduction scheme
which I called mixed function efficient
with predicates using any any a be
scheme so let me try to explain what the
public function class and the secret
function class is for this particular
mix function encryption scheme so the
mixed function encryption scheme over
here it contains it is basically
parameterize by three things on message
m a public policy file and a private
policies I and each circuit that we can
encrypt in this system can take as input
two strings string X 1 and string X 2
we say that this function outputs the
message m and the public policy file as
long as the public policy file accepts
the first input and the secret policy
file access the second input so you
basically are doing like an a/b check
policy check well you have a public
policy as well as a private policy if
both the policies are satisfied on these
two distinct inputs then you basically
leak out the message otherwise you do
not reveal the message you can just
imagine it's like an a/b system with
some sort of a private policy mode in
the public mode of this mixed Fe M X
function caption system the only private
function that we can encrypt is the
unity function so sighs always unity
like the constant one function but in
the secret key mode it can be a much
much much stronger class so any
questions about the functions that we
can encrypt in these cases so this the
first one was mixed function encryption
in which the public encryption class was
just unity function the second one is
more like an AV system in which we also
have potentially capability to encrypt
some hidden or some some secret
predicates as part of the policy so now
we were able to show that if you have a
mixed function encryption scheme for
these general predicates and then you
instantiate these mixed functionally
deficient for general predicates with
the simple predicate of comparison
basically if you replace si with the
comparison with greater than equal to I
for any input I of your choice then that
particular mixed function reduction
scheme which I call mixed function
reductions of comparisons that is
actually quite useful for realizing
something called trader tracing and so
this entire lifting procedure is finally
able to give us a trader tracing system
that we didn't know how to do how to
build from stand assumptions before this
work so any questions about the function
classes that I'm proposing over here
okay so since then that work the work of
Jillian friends they were able to show
that they were able to provide alternate
constructions for the unity mix function
caption scheme just basically trying to
capture a much wider class of functions
that you can encrypt in the secret key
more recall in our original construction
we could only encrypt these log space
computable functions whereas Jillian
friends they were able to show in the
secret key mode now he can potentially
encrypt arbitrary polynomial size
circuits as well and in a lot of
follow-up works it was shown that this
expanded so basically there are lot of
nodes on this in this picture you can
achieve not only traitor tracing but a
lot of different variants of traitor
tracing like actually a straighter
tracing or embedded annotate ray tracing
and as I'm going to highlight towards
the end of the talk
this picture is actually much wider it's
much bigger and there are a lot of more
nodes that we have explored since the
original work and maybe potentially you
can explore more nodes in this
particular graph and get more many more
GUI applications but in the remaining
talk I'm going to tell you how to build
trader tracing from learning with errors
we have the paradigm of mixed function
corruption we have this transformation
alright so looking ahead to the
remaining talk the remaining part of the
talk is divided into sort of four
components the first component is going
to try and it will be in trying to
understand the problem of traitor
tracing itself
I mean unclaimed mixed function is
useful and I'm claiming it's useful for
trader tracing but what really is the
problem of trigger tracing that I follow
up by trying to show how to build trader
tracing we have this mixed function
encryption paradigm then I will show how
to construct mix function encryption
using these lattice tricks and finally
if time permits I'm going to tell you
something about some new lattice tricks
that were developed as part of this work
all right so let's just try to
understand the problem of trader tracing
consider us very simple scenario is
considered a broadcast environment where
we have n users who are basically n
recipients who have a partial seat they
have their decryption keys so user one
has seated SK 1 user 2 has C 2 is K 2
and user has secret es KN and there are
some master public parameters some
master public e PK in a broadcast
environment what you can do is that I
want to send a mess
hm - all these end recipients what I can
do is that I can encrypt my message
using this master public key and send
that sack text over over this broad
public broadcast channel and all these
recipients they can decrypt that suffix
learn the underlying message using their
private decryption keys so that's just
the general concept of God cast
encryption as you might have already
heard of now this the standard security
requirement that we have for a broadcast
encryption is called the semantic
security which basically states that as
long as an adversary does not get to see
any of the decryption keys any of these
authorized decryption keys it will not
learn anything about the message m that
was encrypted so I'm good but it turns
out as long as the adversity gets to see
even just one secret key the SIS the
security of the system completely breaks
down now what if we are working in a
piracy prone environment so we have
taught casting in a piracy patron
environment suppose the university
actually is able to cut up a few of
these parties in the system suppose it
corrupts a second and the last party in
the system so it has a secret he escaped
- it has a secret es KN what the
adversity can potentially do is that use
the secret information to create some
sort of a decryption or decoding device
this device can take as input ciphertext
in to get under the master public key
and recover the plaintext intricate
inside the self text since the adversity
has the secret is it can potentially
create such a decoding device and this
could crack or create a great amount of
havoc in the in the broadcast system
because you you you're just causing
privacy right so a treaty tracing system
actually tries to combat this problem a
traitor tracing system says that if an
adversary can create such a decoding
device then we will be able to just look
at this decoding device just give an
input X input/output access to this
recording device we will we will be able
to find the indices of the users whose
keys were used in creating this decoding
device so if uses two three four and
five something like that suppose they
were corrupted then the tracing
algorithm will find out at least one
user whose keys were whose key was used
in creating this decoding device so what
makes the problem of trader tracing
interesting and a bit challenging is
that the adversity over here which gets
to corrupt these secret keys can be
potentially using any arbitrary
technology in order to in in order for
while being able to
create this recording device for
instance it could use some sort of
hardware or it could use some sort of
software of the station or it could also
use the fact that the adversity can
corrupt multiple secret keys not just
one and try to throw off the trace so
this is what something that makes the
problem a bit challenging also what
makes the problem of trade addressing
interesting in terms of applications in
terms of real-world applications is that
we want this parameters of the system to
be 16 leave on the shaft X length the
public key the secret in everything in
this scheme do not draw with the total
number of users hand but instance
suppose the number of users is a million
or a billion then you don't phone the
self text or all the other parameters to
grow with 1 billion you want to just
pretty succinct and still provide all
these guarantees so having succinctness
and having these strong notions of
traceability
that's what combining these two things
together that's what makes this problem
a bit challenging so let me try to
formalize the notion of data tracing a
little bit more so in terms of
algorithms the trace a trader tracing a
system consists of three algorithm that
you've already seen a set up encryption
and decryption a little the set up
algorithm generates the master secret is
the public keys and user decryption keys
using the encryption algorithm you can
encrypt any message any of your choice
and using the decryption algorithm and
any user decryption key any key SK 1 up
till s KN you can decrypt the ciphertext
and uncover the underlying message and
so that's the correctness of the system
so this is basically the usual broadcast
encryption algorithms for public
encryption system what makes the notion
of radio tracing interesting is the
existence of the special tracing
algorithm the tracing algorithm it
actually takes us input the master
secret key a pair of messages m0 m1 and
it gets
Oracle access to this decoding device T
and what the tracing algorithm outputs
is that it outputs a set T a set of
users a subset of users from 1 through n
and what the tracing algorithm is trying
to say is that if the decoding device
that adversely created it is a good
decoding device it can it can decrypt
decryptions it can decrypt encryptions
of m0 and m1 then in that case the set T
will figure out at least will point to
at least one user whose key was used in
creating that particular decoding device
so let's just try to formula is the
security requirement that we require
from Fira tracing so its capture
the following security game between a
challenge and adversity as we are quite
used to so the game starts as follows
the diversity sends over the total
number of users N and says to the
Challenger a challenger please to a set
up for end users and send over the
public key to me the challenger obliges
sends over the public key then the
adversary says ok I want to now corrupt
the following set s of fuses give me the
corresponding secret keys
the Challenger VN obliges and gives the
corresponding secret keys what the
adversity finally needs to output is
that it needs dog but a decryption
device is decoding device T a pair of
messages m0 and m1 then the Challenger
what it does that it honestly runs the
tracing algorithm given all these inputs
and let P be the output of the tracing
algorithm we say a trader tracing system
is a secure tracing system if it
satisfies two conditions one is sort of
like a soundness condition and the other
one is more like a completeness
condition the sound is condition at a
high level it's saying that the
Challenger the orbit racing algorithm
should not falsely accuse any user of
cheating in a little more detail you
don't want to falsely accuse anyone we
want to say that if there exists an
index I in set T then it should not be
the case that index I was not in the set
s that was corrupted by the user by the
InfoSphere so the probability this
happens should be negligible because if
it's not negligible then that means the
tracing algorithm is actually falsely
accusing users of cheating which is not
good for applications the second
condition is more like the correctness
condition which says that if the
decoding device that the adversary
created it's a good decoding device it
can do it can distinguish between
encryptions or m0 and m1 with some
non-negligible probability then in that
case the set T that the tracing
algorithm outputs it should not be empty
which basically means you should catch
someone if the adversity is able to
create a good device then you should
actually find someone the first one says
don't find someone falsely and the
second one says find someone and if you
combine then you get that you will catch
at least a user whose keys was actually
corrupted if there is a good device so
any questions about the concept of
credit racing
so until now what I have done is that I
have defined something called mixed
functional trypsin and I have defined
something called trait of tracing so
mixed function krypton recall has this
general function reduction with two
modes public mode of secret mode and
trader tracing has this capability of
tracing traders in a system when some
sort of piracy is happening now next I'm
going to show how to actually build a
trader trading system from a mixed
function encryption system but for
comparison's so this is also the mixed
functional efficient system
for comparison's is also regarded is
also widely known as privately broadcast
encryption in the literature
I just want to regard this as mix from
mixed functional picture comparisons for
the purposes of this talk now a trader
tracing system consists of these four
algorithms right set up encryption
decryption and tracing algorithm
so first let's see how to do the tree
setup induction and decryption for the
trader tracing system if we have a mixed
function encryption system so the idea
is as follows first let's look at setup
what we going to do is that between this
in pinna in the mixed function kitchen
setup that's going to give us a master /
in a master secret key he said that as
the street-racing master public inner
master secret key now we have to
generate n decryption n decryption keys
for any users in system what we do is
that we turn the mixed if he he
generation algorithm where the input
that we feed to the algorithm is an
index from 1 through n so the first user
we take as input 1 and give it c to t sk
1 the second user we use input 2 and
give it c to t sk 2 and so on and that's
going to be our trader tracing set up so
the trader tracing encryption algorithm
we want to encrypt a message n the idea
as you could expect we are going to use
the public encryption algorithm for the
mixed function corruption scheme recall
the mixed function efficient scheme that
we have in the public key mode we can
intervention of the form C prime M of
unity and C prime M of unity if you
recall the functionality of C prime M of
unity it says that this function is
going to output the message M on all
inputs X because unity satisfies all
inputs X unity of X is equal to 1 so
that means C prime M of unity of X is
equal to M so that's what these are the
functions that we encrypt in the public
key mode next decryption is just going
to be
to mix the a decryption algorithm and
you can simply see correctness by the
fact that C prime M I of X is equal to 1
now if I'm say the first user I have a
secret key for input 1 and my secret is
satisfied this predicate so that means I
can learn the underlying message M
so hopefully the correctness of this
straight of tracing system makes some
sense any questions about just
correctness okay so let's just try to
see the more interesting algorithm that
how we
Allyson's in this way in this particular
scheme so the idea is as follows I hope
you can still see my slides because the
connection seems to be a bit unstable
okay so let me start by recalling the
function classes so recall that in the
public key mode we were encrypting C
prime M of unity in the secret key mode
we could encrypt C prime M of comparison
functions which is greater than equal to
I this C prime M of greater than equal
to I is the following function it takes
us input string X and it basically
checks if X is greater than this
threshold this threshold I if X is
greater than equal to I then output the
message n otherwise do not output in it
so that's the function that we can
encrypt in the secret key mode the
tracing algorithm it receives as follows
it starts by firstly encrypting
computing the secret he self text a
secret encryption in the mixed function
Direction system of C prime MF greater
than equal to 1 note that C prime M
Ephrata than equal to 1 can be decrypted
by all any users in the system because 1
is greater than equal to 1 2 is greater
than equal to 1 and so on
so the tracing algorithm does is that it
creates a size like something like this
it runs the decoding device because it
gets Oracle access to the decoding
device
it runs the decoding device on the
ciphertext and it basically checks
whether the decoding device works
correctly or not and the tracing
algorithm does is for normally many
times doing this polynomial many times
helps in helps the helps the tracing
algorithm in coming up with an estimate
what's the successful decryption
probability that the decoded works for
these types of serfs texts suppose
that's et person in this case the
tracing I will get them proceeds as
follows
now it revokes away the access of the
first user what it does is that if you
see what's happening and I'm going to
change the predicate the secret
predicate that I'm going to encrypt in
the secret key mode now instead of
encrypting C prime M of greater than
equal to 1 I am going to encrypt C prime
M of greater than equal to 2 now this
ciphertext cannot be decrypted by the
first user but can only be decrypted by
the second third and so on all these
users now I'm going to again estimate
this successful decryption probability
for these cycles of these types of
circuit X now I'm going to keep on going
this I'm going to revoke away that so
the second user as well and I keep on
doing that until i revoke away all the
all the users access because in the end
I'm going to encrypt to a function
something like C prime M
greater than equal to n plus one note
that all the inputs 1 2 3 up till n they
are less than n plus 1 so that means
they do not satisfy this predicate so in
that case C prime M of X for all X and 1
through n is going to output pod so in
that case the adversity or in that case
the algorithm the secret keys cannot
decrypt this particular circuit text
what the tracing algorithm is going to
do is that it's going to observe
wherever there is a gap so right now we
can observe there's a gap between the
successful decryption probability once
we move from 2 to 3 and we move from 6
to 7 and we moved from 8 to 9 the
algorithm is going to say the uses 3 7 &
9 are compromised because when I removed
away their access that's when I saw a
dip in the decryption probability I saw
there was a question let me answer the
question and after that I will describe
the intuition behind the proof that why
this tracing schema seems to work so
where's your question for you it says
why is it important that yeah this
happens in the secret bit Moria so it's
a good question why does this happen in
the secret key mode okay it could be
excellent if couldn't happen in this
public key mode because in the public
key mode anybody can perform the chasing
operation but recall the mixed function
efficient scheme that we have the public
is so there are two different function
classes that we can entertain the public
key mode so the white thing represents
the public key functions and the black
thing represents the secret key
functions this dark mode in the public
key mode we can only encrypt the unity
function the unity function is
performing the simple shape it's always
outputting 1 it's not checking this
comparison predicate whereas the secret
key mode have we have this comparison
predicate and that's why we can only
perform tracing in the secret key mode
now you might wonder that ok hey is
there a possibility of having this
comparison in this in the public key
mode itself that's a much stronger class
of mixed function reduction we don't
know how to build that from standard
assumptions so that's very interesting
open problem that I'll get to later so
seems like an another question there is
no other predicate Institute key mode
yes right now I'm showing that traitor
tracing can be built from mixed function
encryption for comparison predicates so
that's all I need but
going forward I'm going to actually show
to you that we can actually mix function
efficient where the predicates that we
can encrypt in the secret key mode is a
much larger class but for trader tracing
for just regular trade to trace
encryptions for the function C prime M
of greater than equal to one this
particular policy circuit and this claim
is supported by the third property the
third property of mixed function
efficient states that the type of the
ciphertext is hidden asked long as the
seek as long as the adversity cannot
reveal distinction between the functions
that even trip so note that the
adversity potentially gets to CC trade
keys for inputs 1 2 3 up to n on all
these particular input C prime M of
unity and C prime M of greater than
equal to 1
they output the same value so that means
this mode should be hidden because the
output function is the same my next
claim is that this any decoding device
cannot basically decrypt the secret
cannot learn anything from secret
encryptions for the predicate c prime m
of greater than equal to n plus 1 so in
these types of ciphertext i have revoked
away the access of all n users so by the
security property of the secret key mode
the secret is safe text hiding property
it states that any size text you do not
learn any non-trivial information about
the self text so recall the message m is
a non trivial information in this case
because you cannot recover the message m
from such an encryption by just running
the decryption algorithm because the
decryption algorithm is for inputs or
just you have C to T's for inputs 1 to
obtain m and all those inputs do not
satisfy the steady care finally I also
claim that the mix function krypton
scheme we have these secret keys of text
right these secret ACEF texts are going
to hide the index of the that VI encrypt
so we have we are in fittings these
comparison indices right so my claim is
that and adversely cannot distinguish
whether I revoke the way ayat users
access it can not distinguish
distinguish between encryptions of C
prime M of greater than equal to I
versus C prime M of greater than equal
to I plus 1 so they're moving away
ayuk users access as long as it does not
get to see the ID secret key so only
when this adversity gets to see the
ayats seated key that's when it can
notice that particular gap otherwise
they should it should not be able to
change the successful
probably the decoding device and this
again follows by the second security
property of the mixed function efficient
scheme which is the secret key hiding
the which is the ciphertext hiding
property in the secret key mode and
combining all these properties all these
claims it seems like we can come up with
a nice proof of security for this
traitor placing system now there are
some subtleties that I'm not going to go
into for instance I'm just going to
briefly remark what the subtleties are
so note that in create a tracing system
the adversities actually outputting a
decoding device whereas in a mixed
function tradition scheme we have to
distinguish between a distribution of
say a public key subtext or secret key
cipher text so it's not really clear how
you can use just a decoded is a lengthy
to perform that distinguishing of that
you have to handle some some technical
subtleties over there and which arrived
in the proof now another another
important part that you have to handle
in the proof is that in the tracing
algorithm that that I described the
tracing algorithm is actually sampling
or normally many an unbounded number of
secret conviction queries but in the
proof the adversary the Challenger can
only or be as a reduction algorithm can
only get to see a bounded number of
secret key encryption valleys
so we have to take care of that in the
proof that we don't overshoot in terms
of making C to commercial queries and
just a quick brief remark these things
can be handled by something called the
double run trick and please feel free to
bug me after the talk if you are
interested in how to handle these
subtleties I saw there was Photoshop
there two more questions yeah so the
first one is by F Gainey and it says is
secretly triggered tracing is easy from
standard assumptions as only need secret
key mode so thanks have give me for the
question good question but it's not easy
it's not unless ya see 2 atleast so what
I'm proposing right now is that I'm
actually giving you a trader tracing
scheme in which you can perform facing
in a secret key mode the second question
by Sergey but what if the adversity
corrupts the first and the last user can
you really catch the last user
absolutely because you can catch the
last user let's just look at this
picture again
so that it's it becomes clear so I
remove look away the access of say the
first n minus 1 users then I also revoke
away the last users access what's going
to
what is that once I woke up with this
access if the adversity is actually
using this particular secret key the
last secret es KN in creating this
decoding device that's when there will
be a gap so it doesn't matter whether
you could have the first use of the
second user any of these users you are
basically remove a access one by one so
I see this another question
the loss in the advantage seems to be
very large if you start with the decoded
that succeeds with probability epsilon
what is the successful success
decryption probability of the tracing
algorithm so okay good question so the
question is the following suppose the
decoding algorithm that the adversity
outputs it it gives only a 1 over lambda
square advantage not more than that but
you know that D always distinguishes
with that much advantage what you can do
is that for such a decoder you can
always figure out at least one trader so
it's not that there will be a a loss in
the advantage that with only certain
probability with 1 over lambda square
probability you can catch it traitor so
you can always catch a traitor
whenever the decoding device is a good
distinguisher so it doesn't matter how
bad the distinguisher is it should just
just be some non-negligible probably an
advantage as soon as decoded has some
non-negligible advantage you can trace
the trader
another question I'm guessing ok so yep
guineas asking secretly function
reduction for comparisons is known from
other assumptions then learning with
errors so yeah so yep Kenny's right if
we had secretly function encryption
succinct secret key from clink of
shrimper comparisons from some standard
assumptions then yes that will give us a
secret key encryption a secret key
trader tracing in which the tracing
algorithm as far as the induction
algorithm is secret key so that is
possible but we also don't have secret
key function gription for comparisons
which is succinct I hope that answers
your question ok so yeah so this was the
truth intuition and now yeah so in the
remaining part so ok until now what I
have told you is that I told you that we
can build a trade a tracing system if we
start with a mix function encryption
scheme for comparisons now I'm going to
show you how to actually build this mix
function gription for comparisons so
first recall
that I had this primitive of mixed
function machine for predicates so mixed
function gription of predicates was able
to encrypt these types of policy
predicates so a policy predicate was
parametrized by a message M a private a
public policy Phi a private policy sigh
and two inputs and it outputs the
message if both the public policy and
the private policy accepts the
corresponding inputs x1 and x2 so now
it's pretty simple you can just use this
mixed function efficient with predicate
to instantiate to get a mixed function
mixed function addition for comparisons
the idea is just that keep the private
policy function si to be the comparison
function greater than equal to I and the
public policy function to be just the
empty function just nothing and that
basically gives you mixed function
reduction of comparisons so it turns out
if you can build mixed function gription
with predicates then you can get just
you can just instantiate for comparison
function classes and that gives you
mixed function encryption for
comparisons and that eventually gives
you see public iterated tracing with a
secret keep tracing mode so now comes
the more interesting part that how we
can actually lift a mixed function
reduction scheme in which there is only
a single function that we can in trip in
the public key mode to a more stronger
mixed function crucian scheme in the
case in which we can encrypt a much
wider class of functions in the public
key mode so I call the starting mixed
function gription scheme to be the unity
or the mix from accepting mixed function
reduction scheme and we are trying to
lift it to a mixed function reductions
in fact ready gates so let's see how to
do this so the setup algorithm of this
mixed function efficient scheme for
predicates it's going to simply run the
ad set up and the unity mixed function
detection set up and it's going to
sample these master public and Master
seated keys you set both the public keys
and the both the secret is ask the
public and secret keys for this new
Mixtec function efficient scheme for
predicates now we want to do the key
generation algorithm
recall that the inputs the attributes or
the inputs for these particular
functions they are two strings strings
x1 and x2 so to generate a secret key
for these particular inputs the mix
function reduction scheme is going to do
the following first we are going to just
take the second input X 2 and we're
going to put through that the mix
function encryption key generation
algorithm for the unity mix function
system it's going to give us a mixed
function reduction scheme for C for
input next to now what I'm going to do
is that I'm going to take this mixed
functional efficiency turkey append it
with the first input x1 and feed that
inside the a ve generation algorithm and
finally I'm going to get an a/b secret
key so what I get is then what I get is
an ABC tricky with the first input x1
and the second input mix functional
encryption secret key for input X 2 and
that's going to be my mixed functional
efficiency tricky for today gates for
this particular case now let's look at
possibly the most complicated slide of
my entire talk which is how to encrypt
these policy circuits c.m fee of unity
in the public key mode using attribute
based encryption and this accepting
mixed function caption what I start by I
start by doing the following
I run the mixed function efficient
public key encryption algorithm for the
unity circle for this unity scheme
recall the unity scheme only takes this
constant one function always accepting
function as an input it's going to give
me a mixed function detection staff text
what the encryption algorithm is going
to do is that it's going to heart by a
desire text inside this decryption
circuit and this decryption circuit is
going to take as input a mixed function
of trypsin secret key for the unity
system and it's going to output a single
bit 0 or 1 so let me call this circuit
to be a decoding or just this special
policy circuit the mix function
efficiency to size text MFE hcp now I'm
going to define a new policy circuit
theta M fee of unity as follows so theta
takes us input to strings string X and
string Y of appropriate length and what
theta X of Y is going to output it's
going to output the message m that you
had fire inside this as long as the
public policy function accepts the first
input and this circuit D that I computed
by hardwiring the mixer fee function
seated key that accepts the second input
so if V of X and B MF e dot CT of Y is
equal to 1 both of these except then
output the message m otherwise do not
have to the message do not put anything
else so I get this policy circuit this
policy predicate I encrypt this using
the a B
encryption system and I get an a/b
ciphertext and that's going to be my
mixed episodic text so just trying to
adjust here really push this through so
what's happening in the mixed function
detection this public key encryption
algorithm is that first we are running
the public encryption algorithm for the
base system for the very simple system
the simple unity stupid system we are
coming up with a hardwired circuit and
then get using that Hardware circuit
which contains a mixed episode key
inside this fall as a policy circuit
inside a V so the AV scheme consists of
a public policy as well as a seeker and
as well as this particular policy this
decryption of mixed contribution secret
key this mixed encryption ciphertext and
that's going to be at a B public policy
along with the message n so any
questions about the public key
encryption algorithm so we are
encrypting messages M for this policy
circuit fee for unity all right so if
you understand what's happening in the
public key encryption algorithm it will
be pretty easy to extend this to a
secret interruption algorithm for the
function Class C MV of SCI because now
we want to encrypt a much wider class of
these private policies as well so these
SCI is a private policy fee is a public
policy so the way we interpret I is just
me and use the mixed function efficient
secret interruption algorithm now now
instead of so originally we were using
this white box this public encryption
algorithm now we are using this black
box the secret encryption algorithm for
the underlying unity mix fixed function
detection system we feed that in the
private policies I as input
get a cipher text hardwired it and just
do to compute the same function theta
and that then we interpreted using the
ad system and that's going to be the a/b
subtext is going to be the C tricky
subtext for this lifted mixed function
adaption scheme so any questions about
this all right so that's setup
encryption secret key encryption public
encryption
now decryption is pretty simple if you
look at the secret key of this mixed
function addiction scheme it's just a b
e key a sac text is also an a B sub X
simply done the abb caption algorithm
let me try to explain let's just try to
inspect
miss of the scheme so that we at least
understand what's happening under the
hood so the proof of correctness is
going to I'm going to give it in two
parts so I'm going to first prove the
following fact the fact that I'm
claiming is that the circuit d MF e dot
CD that I described on the previous
slides if you feed that a mixed function
detection scheme secret key for input X
2 as an input then that circuit is going
to output 1 so right now inspecting the
correctness in the public key mode of
the mix function detection scheme so in
the public key mode you what we do is
that we encrypt the unity function using
the mix function scheme so unity is an
always accepting function you encrypt
this get a cipher text hardwired this
inside the cipher text and this side
this particular hardwired circuit is
your B circuit d MF e dot C T now in the
key generation algorithm what we do is
that we take the second input we put
that through the mix traffic generation
algorithm and we get a mixed FEC Kripke
now if you look at if you try to feed
this mixed up a secret key as part of
this mixed F as part of this circuit
this is DM e feed of C D circuit then my
claim is that the output is going to be
1 the claim is supported by the fact
that this cipher text encrypts the Unity
function the canonical always accepting
function and I of X 2 is equal to 1 for
all X 2 so that means the fact 1 holds
true
in secret keys secret keys is going to
be equal to 1 so that's fact 1 next I'm
going to claim the folding I'm going to
claim that if fee of X 1 if the private
is the public policy fee satisfies the
first part of the attribute X 1 then the
decryption is actually going to recover
the underlying message M so for that
recall this is what a sacked X looks
like in the public key mode we have this
we have this policy circuit D that are
described on the previous slide and we
have this policy circuit theta that
encrypt in the a B our self text and now
this is the key generation algorithm the
key generation algorithm simply runs an
ad a generation algorithm where the
first attribute is x1 and the second
attribute is a mixed function reduction
scheme a summation a MF e dot secret key
for input X 2 and that's going to be our
ABC trait is going to be the final
secret key now if you try to inspect
this particular line over here you note
that the input that we get an a/b secret
key for is x1 comma MFE dot C Turkey or
x2 now this is the policy circuit that
we encrypt inside the a B self-critic
this takes us input a string X and a
string Y so the string x is x 1 over
here and the string Y is mixed function
election secret key for input X 2 and
now if we inspect this correctness
condition you know that if V of X 1 is
equal to 1 which we have from here if V
of x 1 is equal to 1 which we have in
this case and also we have DMF e dot CT
of this particular secret is equal to 1
then we will output the message m so by
combining fact 1 and the fact that we're
assuming fee of X 1 is equal to 1 we get
this is true so that means in this case
theta is going to output the message M
on these particular inputs and the
correctness seems to follow so combining
factor 1 and n factor we get that the
decryption algorithm actually I mean the
scheme is correct in the public key mode
now you can pretty easily extend this
correctness argument for the secret key
mode itself so in the secret key mode
even encrypt instead of unity we will
encrypt a general policy circuit sigh
ands I will basically incur in this fact
one sophist I will change of fact one is
stated but rest everything else is going
to stay the same
now due to time constraints I'm not
going to
tell you more about how to prove correct
how to prove security of the scheme but
I'm going to just give you a very high
level some cliff notes about how we can
prove security of this transformation
our idea is as follows so if you
basically again let's just look back at
the public encryption in the secret
encryption cell fixed so if you look at
these two slides so what's changing
between these two slides it's just
basically this particular block the
public key mode we are using the mixed
Fe public key encryption algorithm in
the secret key mode we're using this
mixed a feeling from a secret key
encryption algorithm so now if I want to
claim that a public is a text of this
scheme is different from the secret keys
effects of this new scheme then all I
want to rely on is that the mixed
official text of the underlying basic
unity scheme is indistinguishable from
the secret key subtext for the
underlying unity scheme so just so that
means if I use public seated in
distinguish many property the property 3
of the underlying unity scheme then I
can claim the public secret
indistinguishability for this general
predicate scheme as well and now
similarly you can just you can just
combine the AV security property along
with the mix function caption scheme
public as respectively the secrets affix
hiding property to get the corresponding
mixed Fe public and secret key
subsection properties yeah if we can
discuss that offline if it's interesting
but here let me move on so now this is
the picture that I have uncovered for
you so far I've shown you that we can
built ray tracing from Nick's data for
comparisons we can instantiate Mixtec
for comparisons using mixed function
gription for predicates and i've shown
you that how we can just lift a mixed
efficient detection scheme for general
predicates using a ve now finally to
complete this picture we want to show
how to actually build these unity mix
functional scheme from that from
learning with errors so now there are
two pathways for this construction so
the first one is the original
construction that we proposed in which
we provided a direct construction for
mixed Fe for unity from learning with
errors but right now I'm going to
describe a much cleaner and simpler
construction from the paper of Yale en
France where they proposed a
construction for mixed function
efficient scheme for unity functions
from just lockable obfuscation
since you've already seen a talk on
lockable obfuscation it is wise to see
just use lockable office kitchen to also
build mix function trypsin because that
will give you a flavor of the power of
mix function efficient and as well as
locking block discussion so I'm going to
focus on this part now so I'm going to
show that a unity or an accepting mix
function efficient scheme can be
constructed just from lockable
obfuscation just like let's just quickly
recall what lockable obfuscation is a
lockable obfuscation scheme consists of
two algorithms and obfuscation algorithm
in evaluation algorithm the obfuscation
algorithm it takes as input a program or
message M that you want to encode and a
log string alpha and the evaluation
allocated on given input X u n you
evaluate it and you either get a message
or a bawd string and the correctness of
the system states that if the input X on
which you evaluate the facility program
that matches the lock string alpha then
in that case evaluating the obfuscated
program is going to recover the message
MSG otherwise you're not going to learn
anything and that's lockable obfuscation
in a quick linker of that so our idea
behind constructing accepting mix
contribution via lockable obfuscation
it's pretty simple in venkatesh talk he
described to you that there is a way to
turn any encryption scheme into it's
anonymous counterpart using lockable
obfuscation ideas actually building upon
that thing so a one-line summary of the
construction is that we are going to
anonymize a bounded collision secret key
functional difference scheme so we
already have bounded collision secret
function detection scheme and we are
going to use the occupy opposition to
anonymize that and that's going to give
us an accepting mix function reduction
scheme so just quickly so the setup and
key generation algorithm for our mix
function detection scheme are going to
be this stay the same as they were for
the C tricky function adaption scheme
now what is the public interaction
algorithm note that in the public key
encryption algorithm for mixed Fe we
want to encrypt the canonical one
function this unity function always
constitute one function and the
algorithm what it does that it simply
samples and random obfuscated program
literally a garbage program so so what
when gate I was saying a garbage totally
random program that's what we said a
public key encryption algorithm to be
now in the secret key mode we actually
want to encrypt a policy function f
so we are going to come in goat that
using lockable obfuscation and we going
to proceed as follows we are going to
first start by sampling a random log
string alpha of appropriate length then
we have this function f that we want to
encrypt right what we going to do is
that we are going to set a function f
alpha as follows f alpha it outputs
alpha alpha on input X if f of X is
equal to zero so basically f alpha of X
outputs alpha f of X is equal to 0
otherwise it outputs a special reject
simple mod what we going to do is that
we encrypt this function f alpha naught
F but the function f alpha using the
secret key function induction get a
cipher text and then what we do is that
we take the secret key F a decryption
circuit which takes us input a secret
key and a ciphertext we hardwired the
cipher text inside the circuit this is a
new program which takes us input a
secret key and outputs a message and we
are going to lock you Billy of the Skip
is program the lock value alpha and the
message is going to be zero and this is
going to give us a mixed function
gription ciphertext and this mixed
function gription cyclic is simply an
obfuscated program so know that an
obfuscated program is a mixed official
text and a mixed Fe secret key is just a
simply a secret key function reduction
secret key so the decryption algorithm
as you could have imagined is just the
evaluating the off-script program as was
there in the case of other anonymizing
constructions so just to give you a
quick feel of it let me try to explain
why correctness seems to work for this
construction so recall that this is the
policy function this is the program P
that we opt is getting the secret key
mode so this hardwire is the induction
of F alpha now note that if f of X is
equal to 0 then if I try to evaluate the
program P on C to D s KX the secret
functional gription secret key then PS K
of X is equal to going to be equal to 0
why because sk of x if you run through
this detection circuit it's going to
output alpha because f of f of x is
equal to 0 now the office security of x
is equal to alpha then by correctness of
the lockable obfuscation scheme we have
that evaluating this circuit is going to
output 0 which was the message and note
that f of X is equal to 0 so that means
evaluate ILDA of sk of x is equal to f
of x so if f of X is equal to 0 you
value 8 correctly and if f of X is
equal to one then this program is going
to look like a garbage program in that
case you're going to just output some
special reject simple and then in that
you could regard as like to the one
function all right so this sort of
basically completes the picture of Fredo
tracing so until now I've shown you that
we can built right or tracing via this
paradigm of mixed function addition
trying to lift these smaller computers
to largest function classes and then
setting them appropriately to get new
applications and do that and I actually
gave you how to instantiate mixed
function detection scheme for unity
functions using these using lockable
obfuscation now how much time do I have
some Jim
you basically have one minute left okay
I don't have too much time yet
so okay so what I was planning to do
originally I was planning to so since
the construction for the original
construction for lockable obfuscation oh
sorry I think we start at five minutes
right so you can take maybe like six
minutes yeah okay great okay so if I
have something I might just use that
time so yeah so what I'm planning to do
next is that until now I told you how to
instantiate this entire paradigm but
what I also want to give you leave you
with are just some new cool tricks that
be proposed in the original construction
so the first construction that we
provided for mix function encryption
scheme that was a direct construction
from lattices and that had some cool new
features and it seems like those
features have not been exploited by
other lattice based works as of now
because there seems to be another
pathway to build it treated pretty
pleasing without going through that
through that construction but since that
construction is a ham hock so I'm not
going to dive into that construction but
I'm going to just give you some nice
features of that construction so that
the original construction that we
provided for general branching programs
so it has a totally new structures so in
today's to talks in delays talk and then
key the stock they were talking about
the gs-15 way of encoding tranching
programs or performing computation using
these chains right so in the
construction that we proposed for mixed
function reduction scheme we proposed a
totally different structure that so far
it's unclear whether you can write in
terms of gs-15 semantics so it seems
like it's a totally it's it seems to me
as of now that it's a third type of
encoding strategy for encoding branching
programs and it has a totally different
proof strategy that deviates quite
significant before
other proof techniques that have been
developed in lattice paste works so it
is possible those might be useful in
some other context I mean completely as
part of the proof in order to prove the
security for scheme we propose something
called enhanced status trapdoors we
basically prove some stronger properties
about lattice tab dose and which would
very crucial in probing security of a
scheme so in the remaining thing I'm
going to just quickly tell you about the
enhanced status tablet properties just
to give you a quick flavor of that is
trapdoors and these enhanced properties
and then I'm going to conclude with some
open questions and the summary all right
so if you were attending to either stock
from the bootcamp you would have already
known this lattice trapdoors so that
establish are like the party lemon or
red in butter of lattice base
cryptography they are two algorithms
trajan and sample pre algorithm the
trapdoor generation algorithm it takes
as input a dimension for matrix a
modulus Q and it outputs a matrix a
along with some turbulence formation and
the property is that the matrix a it
looks like a random matrix as long as I
do not get to see the trap information
but if I have the travel information
then what I can do is that I can run
this sample pre algorithm for any matrix
u that is supplied to me and I can
create I can sample matrix s such that a
times s is equal to u over mod Q and S
has a structure that has short entries
it does not have large entries mod Q now
the shorthand used in all the prior
talks was just this inverse of U so a
inverse is not a matrix inversion
operation it it's a shorthand for the
sample pre algorithm so these are
lattice tabular algorithms and they have
been some useful properties that have
been used in prior works about lattice
Travels algorithms in this work P
of algorithms it is just identical to
usual lattice structure algorithms
what makes this lattice in half that
established a becomes interesting is
that they provide some stronger security
guarantees so in the world people to
propose two nice security properties
about these enhanced lattice shadows so
the first property that I'm going to
describe is what I call the row removal
property so the removal property goes as
follows the Challenger it's a it's a
game between and challenging adversary
the adversity starts by sending a matrix
C so it sends the matrix C to the
Challenger and the Challenger does the
following the Challenger
it runs the trapdoor generation
algorithm for appropriate dimensions at
examples of matrix a along with the
tabular information and this matrix a
can be interpreted as up top matrix a 1
in a bottom matrix a T and then what I'm
going to do is that the Challenger is
going to sample a random matrix taller
it's going to upend the matrix C
supplied by the bursary and the dollar a
random matrix it's going to upend the
row wise and then it's going to sample a
matrix you using the [ __ ] a sample tree
algorithm and the travel information
such that even times U is equal to C and
a2 times u is included and a matrix that
the Challenger chose and the claim here
is that the adversary is not I'm going
to give the adversary the matrix a 1 a 2
and this matrix U and the claim is that
the adversity cannot distinguish whether
I gave it the inverter
whether I gave it these matrices a1 a2
and you sampled this way along with the
travel information or if I only sample
the top part of the matrix only the even
part of the matrix which I call D in the
bottom slide along with the trapdoor and
the the bottom part q as a random matrix
if I just break out this bottom part of
the matrix from the trapdoor sampling
algorithm and I just sample matrix U as
a pre-image of C with respect to be
using the trapdoor algorithm then the
adversity should not be able to tell
whether a to the bottom part was sampled
with the upper part or not basically it
says you can remove rows of the rows
from the matrix from which yours for
which you're doing a champion tableau
generation algorithm for now any
questions about the removal property I
mean okay let me just push through and
we can have questions later on so the
second property that we were able to
prove in this work is what's called the
table
switching property again it's described
via security came between a challenge
and inversely in the game starts as
follows so the adversity it sends in a
matrix see a matrix Z zero and matrix Z
one now what the Challenger does is that
it samples a matrix a asked before a1
and a2 along with chapter information
and then it's going to sample a matrix u
such that even times U is equal to C and
a2 times u is equal to going to be
either Z 0 plus noise or is going to be
equal to Z 1 plus noise and the claim is
that the adverse we can not distinguish
whether it received a matrix a 1 and a
matrix u we do not give it matrix a to
you only give it the top matrix a 1 and
the this this mapping matrix U and it
cannot distinguish whether the matrix U
is targeting Z 0 or Z 1 in the bottom
part and in the paper we were actually
able to prove a much stronger version of
these two properties
I'm only here describing a
simplification over it seems like a
non-interactive assumption in the paper
we were able to prove some stronger
properties some stronger versions of
that which were very crucial for the
proof so with that let me just try to
conclude and let me just try to first
show you the revisited picture of this
mixed function detection scheme since
the original work on credit tracing we
have seen that this picture is quite big
actually so there are a lot of nodes and
and possibly a lot of unexplored nodes
in this graph right now and we have seen
that mixed function [ __ ] ssin is a very
interesting primitive that you can use
to unlock these cool new applications
that we will previously unknown that we
only knew from obfuscation a function
encryption so maybe a lot of you can
contribute in just expanding this
picture and just plotting more nodes in
this particular graph and a quick
summary so in this work I told you about
mixed function reduction I told you that
we can flip the we can play with the
having two modes of encryption in a
function detection scheme is a powerful
thing to have because now we can play
with this gap you can have a less
expressive mode with more security and a
more expressive more with less security
and if you can play with this
appropriately then we can get
cooling applications and as the couny
applications were having a nice paradigm
for tracing in encryption systems in the
secret racing mode and also I just
briefly highlighted that we provided a
mixed epoch instruction directly from
lattices
and it seems to significantly depart
from the digit style encoding schemes
and maybe those ideas could be used in
some other context as well and we also
proposed something like this new
enhanced lattice travel techniques and
maybe these might also seem other
applications so just ending with some
open questions a very natural open
question at this point might be all the
applications that I've described so far
they have some tracing flavor to them
mixed function addiction seems quite
interesting but as of now it's not very
clear that whatever other applications
there could be of mixed functional
deficient schemes beyond theta tracing
well it should be a possibility maybe we
can use this gap between public and
secret key modes to get something more I
mean one example I could throw
potentially is that of adaptive security
recording at active security when you're
trying to adapt to security of a
primitive like attribute based
encryption scheme we have two parties
the parties over there could be a
challenger and an attacker and the
parties have different powers the
Challenger can potentially have some
master secret keys but the attacker is
only mugging in the public key mode so
basically maybe we might be able to use
this mixed if function gription maybe
not directly maybe not even have
sections but possibly the underlying
techniques to prove some sort of
adaptive security for some primitives
what about public tracing right now all
electric really relied on was the gap
between this public and a secret key
mode and we can't have function
detection for general function for
general predicates maybe publicly but
maybe public tracing could be done but
it seems like a little bit far-fetched
cool given our current approved
techniques now another important
question over here could be if you look
at all these pictures all the graphs
that I pointed out a natural question
could be can you actually broaden the
this paradigm of mixed function
detection can they be some other
variants of mixed function reduction
that might open up some cooling
applications so it turns out yeah in an
upcoming work we have some nice
extensions of mixed function efficient
schemes to some other variants and we
have some nice applications of that as
well and it seems like we have a lot of
other variants of mixed function
reduction scheme that can be considered
but it's not very clear right now what
other applications there could be so if
you have any cooling applications that
you feel like mixed function could be
used in just feel free to contact me
after the talk and it'd be good to
discuss some constructions then we have
for this and maybe they could be some
cooling applications and finally yeah so
they could there be
other constructions or just other
applications of the construction that we
proposed on the lattice toolkit so for
instance in an independent work jalebi
northern ho Tech they also proposed they
also discovered a simplification of the
lattice tablet properties that we
discovered in this work and they were
able to show that these properties can
actually be used to prove something that
we didn't know how to prove before they
were able to construct a lockable
obfuscation scheme for general transit
programs directly using these lattice
turbo techniques national question could
be can the techniques or can the
construction ideas can they be used to
get something more that I would like to
conclude and sorry for going over thank
you for your attention
thanks Philip so there is a question on
the Q&A which is does the target
switching property hold without errors
or what has we hurdle to realize it
without the error think utility okay
so the targeted switching property does
not hold without so if you don't have
errors at all it does not hold you can
actually distinct I think we had a clear
attack in a sense that you can just
learn a bunch of equations and learn out
some non-trivial information and because
of that it's proposed yeah at least if
you don't have any errors at all in both
of the terms then you can't prove
security but a potential Avenue could be
what if you only add error in one of the
targets so right now I decide to targets
right you add errors in both the targets
both in Z 0 and Z 1 it's not clear if
you add only added in one target then
what happens in that case and what
intuitively goes wrong it's just that a
stupid answer could be the proof doesn't
seem to work that we have four
properties but intuitively you can just
regard this as the following the
adversary has the power to choose the
targets right so if the target that the
adversity chooses suppose it chooses
just the all-0 string it chooses the all
zeros matrix as the target and you don't
add noise to it then what you are
basically getting as part of the secret
free image is sort of some sort partial
trapdoor information because
if you're getting three images of zeroes
then you're getting some captive
information about the underlying matrix
and that seems to be that seems to be
somewhat problematic adding noise takes
away that structure now you don't get
some trapdoor information about the
ladder about the matrix but if you add
if you remove the noise then you get
some sort of trap and information okay
any other questions yes there's one more
question is your main construction for
mixed Fe can you explain again how the
msk is used and why it is not weak and
what are the limitations on the the
class of policy so I'm not sure if I
understand the first part of the
question completely
so the question so can you explain again
how mixed I mean so in this case maybe
we can take it offline and then so
that's a good idea okay so thanks a lot
for all the speakers for today and then
all the participants who who came and
made this online they successful yeah
that's about it who do you have anything
else to add no that's good
so thank everyone and I guess we'll see
you tomorrow okay